all right selena
selena oh where'd you grow up where you
from originally here
in manchester and uh tell me about your
family you had both your parents
growing up or you have both your parents
currently no what do you mean
um my mother she's a drug addict
she had four kids and just let us all
get adopted by parts of the family
oh really so so you've been adopted yes
and how how is your adopted family
my adopted family still
i would have put this i don't i'm sorry
um
my adopted family is my family
already but my aunt is no longer my aunt
she's my mom
oh i see so your your aunt became your
mom yes got it
and is your biological mom still around
she's in and out but when she's around
she's not
the best oh i see
so um how would you how would you
describe your childhood
it seems like you're you're having a
nice happy childhood right yeah
but like when i was little you know i
would
go around my real mom but it just
wasn't good for me as being a little kid
saying that growing up
seeing what the drugs yes no
i've interviewed some other members of
your family and there's it seems like
drugs are
pretty interesting all through clay
county there's drugs but
yeah your family is no exception so yeah
so it's all around you
you're in high school right now yes what
year are you in high school
i'm in 11th grade so you have one more
year
and how do you navigate the the fact
that there are drugs all over your
house or your family i just try to stay
away from it the best i can
for me i don't see that as a lifestyle i
see it as a choice that somebody mates
and it's really broke my family apart to
be honest
yeah it's very destructive yes do you
have friends in school that are
getting playing around with drugs as
well yes
it seems like it seems like it's pretty
prevalent here among the kids among the
adults and it's it's like almost every
family gets touched by it it seems
yeah so how does that affect you when
you go to parties when you socialize and
stuff like that i don't
i stay at the house the most i ever do
is go to one of my cousin's house
or go to my boyfriend's house because
you know i'm not the party pop
so you just you're avoiding it all yeah
that's probably a smart move because
and so what's your plan with after
school after i graduate high school i'm
going to the nursing college in hazard
they have a very good nursing college
and that's my main interest right now is
getting through school and having a good
life
good for you and your long-term plan
would be to get away from this region or
yeah but just to get away from all the
drones i know it's all over the state
but you know i can go on my own
and not have to have the choice of
either
going down the wrong path and messing my
life up
because that's all i've ever been around
yeah now you've seen it firsthand
yeah what the what the end result is
are any members of your families working
or no
they're all just like collecting money
off the government and yeah
trying to bind roads and stuff with it
yeah
well it's great that you are steering
clear of all that that's that's a
wonderful thing for a young
kid here how many kids would you say in
your class or
have the same attitude you do
about 50 of them 52 50 that's good
and then what about uh you know college
is expensive i don't know how much money
your family has
yeah um they have a thing in the state
of kentucky
if you're adopted or in foster care you
can go to college for free as long as
it's in the state
oh really yeah so that'll help you out
yeah a lot
tremendously that's a great thing
wow so i mean do you
how do you view this this region this
you know appalachia seems to be so
affected by drugs and unemployment yeah
and you you see that you're smart you're
a smart girl it seems it's
how do you do you talk with your friends
about like
what the prospects are of staying here
and doing drugs or anything like that
um i've had a few friends that's
already took their own path but they're
finally guiding their way back
and a lot of people getting the
unemployment i know i understand that it
helps them
but sometimes they just want to buy
other stuff with it
how bad does it get in high school
there's how serious is the drug problem
i mean
they even get to where they bring it to
school and sell it
it's bad
and their families have the same
situation you you do
it's in their family so that's what
they've it's the role models they've had
what's been your favorite memory in your
16 years
having my little niece and nephew around
yeah you have a couple
small you have a sister and a niece that
um i have a niece and a nephew
or a nephew yeah and lisa's your
she's my niece my oldest sister had her
and her little brother brayden and
her mother took the same path as
our real mother because she wanted her
attention so bad when she was little
so your mom kind of takes care of
you your niece and my nephew and your
nephew and you guys are all
obviously drug free and yeah and
avoiding everyone that is
yeah who's using right good for you
so what are the best and worst things
about living in appalachia
the good thing is like the scenery
that you can see all over like the fall
and i say about the only bad thing about
around here is
the drug usage and all that like
young kids to adults
can you can you even envision staying
here and trying to find a job and all
that
it's just hopeless it's just helpless
yeah
it's a shame because it's such a lovely
part of the country yeah
but it's just been destroyed yeah it's a
lack of employment in the drugs
and your mom must be very proud yeah
she's
very ecstatic with me yeah
and what what so what i'm like you see
people in your family i mean what
they going through like depression and
jail time and
all kinds of stuff like this right yeah
so that's such a great warning sign for
you just to
just stare clear that's
you have a scared straight program right
your own living room
yes and what do you think of this life i
mean
what do you think the future is for
appalachia
i'd say if the people that wants help
actually gets it
and sticks to it this could be an
amazing place
but if they continue on the path their
own there's prob there's no hope
for none of them yeah and what do you
think the most important
lesson you've learned in your 16 years
has been don't do drugs
like that's it just don't do drugs no
matter how much you get peer pressured
in
trying to do them just don't do it
that's a great one
all right selena well thank you so much
for sharing your story and i wish you
the best of luck in college and
the rest of your life thank you you're
on the right track
proud of you thank you so much thank you
you